il faut agir avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard
les pêcheurs à leurs amis ce gâchis
une fable de la fontaine des tournées
c'est le fil conducteur de leur
spectacle
ces élèves de 6e du collège raymond
poincaré participe à trier ses jouets un
projet pédagogique c'est de faire
réfléchir et faire s'exprimer les
enfants à propos du recyclage de
l'environnement en général mais là plus
axé sur le recyclage et les déchets et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des déchets à
travers une approche ludique et
artistique où ils vont pouvoir
s'exprimer en créant en écrivant
composeront imaginant des danses et
des textes tout ce qu'ils veulent
accompagnés de leur professeur de
français d'un intervenant
ils créent leur histoire de a à z chacun
ramener un peu de saponé et baala fond
de la tout mélanger et ça fait quelque
chose d'assez d'assez bien avec le prof
etc
même si le produit de base c'est quand
même dont de s'amuser et tout ça c'est
quand même un vrai problème pour
l'humanité
le problème de la pollution du gâchis
mais tout ça leur spectacle c'est le
résultat de six séances d'une heure et
demie de travail étalées sur deux mois
une représentation unique est prévue
durant le mois molière